in berlin wilmersdorf wollten heute
mehrere männer eine bank überfallen
die polizei fahndet mittlerweile mit
hochdruck nach den noch flüchtigen
tätern hier die ganze geschichte
durch dieses loch im zaun sind die täter
offenbar entkommen
ihr weg führte dann auf die nahe
autobahn dort wartete augenscheinlich
ein fluchtwagen berichtete ein zeuge
die räuber brausten davon zuvor waren
sie mit an den pritschenwagen in den
innenhof der bank gefahren
platz einzel gehen sie haben dazu ein
fahrzeug genutzt
sie sind dabei auf sicherheits
mitarbeiter getroffen dann kam es zu
einer schussabgabe zum ihren schüssen
ein sicherheitsmitarbeiter wurde dabei
verletzt
wenn die nachfolger kann und dann gleich
noch was zum verletzungsgrad sagen sie
hat sich der versorgung angenommen
die täter die flüchtigen täter haben
einen verdeckungsmord gelegt in dem
fahrzeug und sind die bereits gesagt
weiterhin flüchtig
der wachmann kam ins krankenhaus
lebensgefahr bestand nicht die bank geht
bislang von sachschaden aus ob wirklich
etwas geklaut wurde war zunächst unklar
scheint aber unwahrscheinlich
bereits mitte juni wurde ein
geldtransporter in der detmolder straße
überfallen
vor wenigen tagen gab es einen überfall
auf einen geldtransporter am
hermannplatz von einer häufung wird die
polizei nicht sprechen
man prüfe aber ob ein zusammenhang
bestehe